i'm guessing neither of you or neither
of anyone here
went through like the fan fiction phase
no not really
have you i went through the harvest moon
fan fiction
what you and the other three people out
there because i because there would be
times when
i would like be watching an anime and
i'd be like man i really want this
couple to get together i'd be really
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm showing my i'm
showing a new side of my degeneracy
but yeah i i i remember the first time
was during like haram anime in harry
manga where
there would be this like there like
obviously there would be a winning girl
and i'd be like but what would happen if
the other girl won
what would happen if the other girl won
i have to agree with that
do you not feel like you're like wasting
time why why why why
why because i've had that exact thing
where it's like
when because like when i was like in uh
like teenage years i was like heavily
invested in like to love her
yeah and i [ __ ] love that but like at
the time i was reading it there wasn't
like a clear winner but there were lots
of potential winners
yeah i want to know i just wanted what
if like
if he got with this girl yeah what would
it be like because because because what
got me into the genji's is that there
are so many anime with like this
romantic subplot
that goes [ __ ] nowhere right and i i
just
i just want to see the ending of that
sublime hypothetical
show not being satisfying but to me it's
like i wouldn't
want a story by an author to then just
be someone's like
i got it from here like you know what i
mean like to me that's weird
like that's why i've never been able to
like get my head around fan fiction
why would you want someone else to write
the story that like because someone else
would only really know
because if you don't have if you can't
get the satisfaction from the official
product
you you just have to search that out
somewhere else it's not like i'm just
like
fine with it having that satisfaction i
don't want to be bothered to imagine
myself therefore for example for example
if there was say
i'm going to bring it up again but if
there was like domestic girlfriends
dojinshi's
i don't need that [ __ ] because they
[ __ ] [ __ ] in this in like the actual
series so like why why would i need
that fanfiction i've never watched an
anime and been like damn i really need
to know what would happen
based on a third party's opinion of what
could happen
if x person got you know what i mean
that sounds weird to me i don't know it
doesn't make sense does it not
am i a crazy guy here i think i think
we're both the crazy ones here
we're both on like two ends of the
extreme where i sometimes
i i it's like an itch that i can't
scratch where like if if there's a
series where i know
i'm never gonna see these people get
together or this this author's never
going to finish it the way
that i would like to finish it that my
girl that i want to win is not going to
win
then i'm going to search out the best
way possible of how to itch that scratch
and it's not just that jin she's like
yeah scratch that yeah
a little bit i remember when i watched
code gios the first time i was like why
didn't lelouch
ever like [ __ ] c2 yeah yeah yeah exactly
therefore you go out and you i'm kidding
i'm
i wanted him to do it because i'm like
homie just yeah because
you're taking over the world let a
little stress out let your hair down
order some pizza and kick back
because here's the thing right here's
the thing i
i can't read a digi for like every
series there are certain series that i
think
i [ __ ] made for the jin cheese and
then i see like one piece though jinxies
and i'm like
why would anyone want to get off of this
that's they're not that that doesn't
seem very like
that's weird let me pick up the error
that doesn't seem very
nakama of these guys i'm gonna say
someone makes sense right
because there's so much sexual
attainment i didn't watch it i was just
saying
names stupid and i didn't care about
aaron mangus but the dojins are [ __ ]
like
i don't know i just i i i can't get my
head around it maybe someday i will but
like
i feel like you just need to see the
good ones yeah you just need to grow a
bit i
i actually actually remember this whole
podcast is connor you just need to try
the good
thing once you find the perfect tag yeah
that's that's it it's game over
yeah this is why i don't get into any
more gadgets i just feel like i'm going
to lose more time and i don't want to
waste any more time well you're using
that time to jack off anyway so it's
like
i spent 10 minutes max jacking off yeah
well you can spend that 10 minutes
reading
no that's too much time because you've
got to go through
find one that you want and i bet you
probably have that thing as well where
it's like netflix where you're like [ __ ]
which one do i want
okay okay here's here's the thing most
of the time when i discover a good
hentai
it's by complete accident how are you
finding this because like normally i'm
just like skip skip skip and i'm like
skip on what huh oh
and sometimes i like i like give it like
five minutes if it's like a anime but if
it's
like i i'm less likely to give it a
chance if it's an anime because with
like dojinshi's
you can just you can read way faster you
know it's like
it's like one on youtube you hear that
1.5 speed button when you're just like i
want to see what happens when i can't be
bothered to like hear
everything at this exact pace do you
ever just like
you just can't find a good one so you're
just like [ __ ] it i'll just i'll just
get off to one of them i'm just trying
to do it because like this is taking too
long
no because i know how to find the good
ones yeah but sometimes i go
it comes like a complete accident where
i start reading i'm like ah this uh this
has got some character development on it
like
maybe i'll give it a shot
if there's like 10 pages uh if the 10
first pages if the 10 first pages go by
and there's no [ __ ]
you know the author has given thought
into the story of this dojin man
you know what i'm talking about joe you
know i'm talking about i don't pretend
like you're unfortunately doing it
that's that's that's always the big tell
when when it doesn't start off by just
[ __ ] straight away
then you know there's a chance that this
guy actually cares yeah they actually
care
and then i don't know being invested in
a story like that's that's kind of how
i got into you know nozakiana and a lot
of other titles that
have like off-course stuff yeah like the
soft-core stuff that's
have sex in them but also you know have
a really good plot that you can get
emotionally invested in
have you ever gotten to an anime through
the dojins yes
have you what have you ever gotten into
an anime because you saw a dojin
absolutely even though you haven't seen
the animated apps are [ __ ] which
which one
okay i remember i actually read code yes
dogens before i watched it
i'm not that degenerative um
i'm trying to think what which one was
it
no no um it's hard for me because again
the only dojians i read that are
parodies of anime
are the ones are the anime series that i
didn't enjoy so
satiate that like space i read the
dojins for it
but i don't know if there is one that
was the opposite
i'm sure there is but they're probably
just like not they're like no no yeah
they're not yeah worthy series right
yeah i guess the best analogy i can i
can say is that
it's it's kind of like um it's kind of
like the difference between
having sex on like a one-night stand and
like having sex when you're in like a
relationship he was a monk
no because that you know there's there's
a difference between you know you know
being
being emotionally invested in the
partners that you're with oh my god
wow only high penetration
excuse me we're a good christian couple
thank you very
bad my bad but i guess that's that's
like the difference between just you
know
have having a quick 10 minute jack off
session to
my god this is like the most degenerate
goddamn podcast
you're watching this with your parents
no one talks about this [ __ ] but we all
experience this and then no one wants to
talk about it i don't give a [ __ ]
everyone wanks let's be honest it's 20
20. everybody wants it everyone wanks
dude
make that a song make it a song
everybody